Let's talk about the reputation of the United
States, the reputation of the United States,
unfortunately.
And I do I take no pleasure in this has imploded
over Donald Trump's failure to properly deal
with Corona virus.
Now, when Donald Trump was elected and very
clearly was incompetent and in over his head,
we talked about how the leader of the free
world, which is not an official title to Coehlo
colloquial term, typically assigned to the
president of the United States.
It's sort of like the the major leader of
the Western democracies.
Typically, it's the president of the United
States when Trump was elected.
Widespread consensus that this is a colloquial
title which shifted to German Chancellor Angela
Merkel.
And then we saw Donald Trump essentially remove
the United States from serious participation
in one of the issues of our time climate change,
claiming that climate change is a hoax created
by the Chinese and pulling the U.S. out of
the Paris Climate Accords.
And immediately the U.S. became a non-player
in figuring out pollution and climate change.
And then I'm skipping some steps.
We got to the disaster.
That is Donald Trump's response on Corona
virus.
And when you look at his actions, it makes
sense that the reputation of the United States
would implode.
Trump didn't take it seriously from day one.
Trump was confused and remains confused about
the difference between a virus and a bacteria.
And he's clueless about medicine and pandemics.
And he, quite frankly, barely appeared to
care for a very long time while other countries
were actually taking this seriously.
He said that the response from Democrats was
meant merely to hurt him politically and use
the word hoax rather than dealing with the
problem.
Trump, then, when he started panicking, realized
he had to take it seriously, went and tried
to poach a vaccine being developed in Germany
merely for American use.
He appears to have interfered with other countries
getting medical supplies while completely
mismanaging our own national stockpile, even
having at one point supplies en route to Thailand
while asking Thailand to send us the same
supplies.
Really the stuff of just utter, utter incompetent
management mismanagement.
He had that phase where his focus was just
repeating the phrase Chinese virus over and
over again rather than actually dealing with
anything.
He's been promoting unproven treatments that
he talks about as if their miracle cure.
So it's an embarrassment and he lies every
day and the world is coming to him for help.
He claims nobody is coming to Donald Trump
for help here.
Can you imagine something more obviously untrue?
The world is going to South Korea for advice,
not Donald Trump.
Now look at the model of South Korea for a
moment.
South Korea had their first case within hours
of the United States having our first case.
South Korea immediately developed a test and
made sure that the test was widespread and
available.
They isolated everyone who tested positive
or even had symptoms and a fever.
They established fever clinics for infected
people.
They did extensive contact tracing and found
and isolated people that were in touch with
those infected.
And their numbers speak for themselves.
We are going to need to do that to prevent
a massive second wave in the fall.
South Korea is the country that did it.
So now you have what makes sense.
You have all sorts of world leaders saying,
listen, the United States needs to rethink
all of that America first stuff.
Stephen Walt, who's a professor of international
relations at Harvard, says that not only are
Trump's actions causing death and economic
misery, they have tarnished our global reputation,
which was already very much damaged merely
by electing Donald Trump in the first place.
And Trump's diplomatic embarrassment after
embarrassment certainly didn't help.
So let's say something about the press briefings
in this context.
Trump does these press briefings.
We've been covering some of them.
There were no press briefings over the weekend.
They're scheduled to get back underway today.
Those are being watched by those other countries
that I'm talking about.
And they're the stuff of nightmares.
Other countries see Trump lying uncontrollably,
Trump attacking journalists and a free press.
Trump recommending unproven treatments despite
having no medical knowledge whatsoever.
Trump saying all of the things that he's been
saying.
And in the end, the saddest part about all
of it is that you.
Essentially have two different realities.
People are watching.
People are reading two different books, so
to speak, about what's going on.
You have the reaction from other countries,
which is this guy is out of control.
He's unhinged.
We need to stay away and actually deal with
countries that know what they're doing.
That's one side.
And then you've got Trump supporters that
just love it.
They watch the press briefings and they see
Trump as tough.
They see him as aggressive as a dealmaker,
is not taking crap from people in the audience
as protecting American interests in being
this heroic savior, by coming to the American
people and telling them, go and try.
Hydroxy chloroquine, what do you have to lose?
Despite the fact that there are significant
side effects and questionable efficacy, every
time he embarrasses himself at one of these
press briefings, the world cringes.
But his followers get riled up that he's doing
a great job.
So we are in real trouble.
The signs were there for a long time.
The kids in cages calling climate change a
hoax.
I could go on and on lying every day.
There were signs of trouble all along.
But the scariest part about it is that while
the world is increasingly getting away from
the United States and our reputation is increasingly
a joke.
Not only do the trumpets love what Trump is
doing.
They are more confident that Trump is doing
the right thing because the world cringes
at what Donald Trump does.
They see it as an endorsement of what Donald
Trump's Trump is doing, and that is one of
the scariest things altogether.